so one
one guy that i've talked to several
times who's slowly becoming a friend
is a guy named elon musk he's a big fan
of hardcore history uh especially
genghis khan
uh series of episodes but really all of
it
him and his uh his girlfriend grimes
listen to it which is
i i know what you like yeah you know
elon okay awesome so
that's like relationship goals uh like
listen to hardcore
history on the weekend with your loved
one okay uh
so let me if i were to look at the guy
from a perspective of human history it
feels like
he will be a little speck that's
remembered
oh absolutely you think about like the
people what will
we remember from our time who are the
people will remember
whether it's the the hitlers or the
einsteins
who who's going to be it's hard to
predict when you're in it
but it seems like elon would be one of
those people remembered
and if i were to guess what he's
remembered for
it's the work he's doing with spacex and
potentially being
the person now we don't know but the
being the person
who launched a new era of space
exploration
if we look you know centuries from now
if we are successful as human beings
surviving long enough
to venture out into the you know toward
the stars it's weird to ask you this i
don't know what your opinions are
but do you think humans will be a
multi-planetary species in the arc
long arc of history do you think elon
will be successful in his dream
and he doesn't he doesn't shy away from
saying it this way right
he really wants us to colonize
mars first and then colonize other
earth-like planets in other solar
systems throughout the galaxy
do you have a hope that we humans will
venture out towards the stars
so here's the thing and this actually
again dovetails do what we were talking
about earlier
i actually first of all
i toured spacex and it is when you you
it's hard to get your mind around
because he's doing what it took
governments to do before yes okay so so
it's incredible that we're watching
individual companies and stuff doing
this
doing it faster and cheaper yeah well
and and and and pushing the envelope
right faster than the governments at the
time we're moving is it's cr
it really is i mean there's a lot of
people who i i think
who think elon is is overrated and
you have no idea right when you go see
it you have no idea
but that's actually not what i'm most
impressed with um
it's tesla i'm most impressed with and
the reason why
is because in my mind we just talked
about what i think is the greatest
threat the environmental stuff
and i talked about our inability maybe
all at the same time
to be willing to sacrifice our
self-interest
in order for the for the goal and i
don't want to put words
in elon's mouth so you can you can talk
to him if you want to but in my mind
what he's done is recognize that problem
and instead of building a car that's a
piece of crap but you know it's good for
the environment so you should drive it
he's trying to create a car
that if you're only motivated by your
self-interest
you'll buy it anyway and it will help
the environment and help us transition
away from one of the main causes
of damage i mean one of the things this
pandemic
and the shutdown around the world has
done is show us how amazingly quickly
the earth can actually rejuvenate we're
seeing clear skies in places species
come
and you would have thought it would have
taken decades for some of this stuff
so what if to name just one major
pollution source
we didn't have the pollution caused by
automobiles right
and and if if you had said to me dan
what do you think the odds of us
transitioning away from that were
10 years ago i would have said well
people aren't going to do it because
it's inefficient it's this it's that
nobody wants to
but what if you created the vehicle that
was superior in every way so that if you
were just a self-oriented consumer
you'd buy it because you wanted that car
that's the best way to get around that
problem of people not wanting to i think
he's
identified that and as he's told me
before
you know when the last time a car
company was created that actually you
know
blah blah blah he's right and so i
happen to feel that even though he's
pushing the envelope on the space thing
i think somebody else would have done
that someday i'm not sure because of the
various things he's mentioned how
difficult it is to start
i'm not sure that the industries that
create vehicles for us
would have gone where he's going to lead
them
if he didn't force them there through
consumer demand by making a better car
that people want it anyway
they'll follow they'll copy they'll do
all those things
and yet who was going to do that so i
hope he doesn't hate me for saying this
but i happen to think the tesla idea
may alleviate some of the need to get
off this planet because the planet's
being destroyed
right and we're going to colonize mars
probably anyway if we live long enough
and i think the tesla idea not just
elon's version but ones that follow from
other people
is the best chance of making sure we're
around long enough to see mars colonize
does that make sense yeah totally
and one other thing from my perspective
because i'm now starting a company
i think the interesting thing about elon
is he serves as a beacon
of hope like pragmatically speaking
for people that started to push back on
our doom conversation from earlier
that a single individual could
build something that
allows us as self-interested individuals
to gather together in a collective way
to actually alleviate some of the
dangers that
face our world so like it gives me
hope as an individual that i can build
something
that can actually have impact
that counteracts the uh
the stalins and the hitlers and all the
threats that face
uh that human civilization faces that an
individual has that power
i didn't believe that the individual has
that power in the
in the halls of government like i don't
feel like any one presidential candidate
can
rise up and help the world unite the
world
it feels like from everything i've seen
in and
you're right with tesla it can bring the
world together
to do good that's a really powerful
mechanism of
you know whatever you say about
capitalism that you can build companies
that start you know it starts with a
single individual of course there's a
collective that
that grows around that but the
leadership of a single individual
their ideas their dreams their vision
can catalyze something that takes over
the world
and does good for the entire world but
if i think but again i i think the
genius of the idea
is that it doesn't require us to go
head-to-head with human nature
right he he's actually built human
nature into the idea
by basically saying i'm not asking you
to be an environmental activist i'm not
asking you to sacrifice to make it i'm
going to sell you a car
you're going to like better and by
buying it you'll help the environment
that takes into account our foibles as a
species and actually
leverages that to work for the greater
good
and that's the sort of thing that does
turn off my little doom caster cynicism
thing a little bit because
you're actually hitting us where we live
right you're you're you're not
you can take somebody who doesn't even
believe the environment's a problem but
they want a tesla so they're
inadvertently
helping anyway i think that's the genius
of the idea
yeah and i'm telling you that's one way
to make love much more efficient
mechanism of change
than uh hate making it in your
self-interest today
just creating a product that uh
leads to more love than uh than hate
you're gonna want to love your neighbor
because you're going to make a fortune
okay there you go that's why you're
right i'm on board
that's why elon said love is the answer
that's i think uh
exactly what he meant
you